[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy analizamos los resultados y
consecuencias de las elecciones de
francia para la unión europea estamos
ante una nueva era que debemos esperar
de la nueva presidencia de manuel macro
no lo analizamos con nuestros invitados
los eurodiputados josé ramón bauzá del
grupo renovar europa bienvenido josé
ramón bueno un placer como siempre
igualmente y también con el eurodiputado
antonio lópez istúriz del partido
popular europeo bienvenido de nuevo
muchas gracias me gustaría empezar con
una pregunta que será para los dos
emanuel macrón ha ganado las elecciones
presidenciales con más de un 58% de los
votos
vemos que europa ha respirado aliviada
pero qué lecturas se pueden sacar de
estos resultados para la unión europea
jose ramon bueno pues son 17 puntos de
diferencia
sumamente importantes porque además
coinciden aproximadamente con esos 15
puntos después del debate que
previamente era muy ajusta y lo que
tenemos que analizar es ese 41% de
populismo porque ese 41% que avala como
mejor resultado en este caso a marie le
pen no hace más que tener en cuenta las
próximas elecciones porque esto es un
sin parar las legislativas de junio que
son sumamente importantes y donde ya he
dicho además que que va a seguir en
marcha pero en cualquier caso es un
resultado sumamente importante porque no
solamente estaba en juego el resultado
final de la presidencia francesa sino
también lo más importante era el modelo
de europa que conocemos porque podría
ponerse en juego si la naval
es más o menos parecido una primera
reacción de alivio por la victoria de
manuel macro nos jugábamos mucho no no
solamente en francia también los
europeos
dicho eso la segunda parte es
preocupación el citado por jose ramon la
cuestión del avance del populismo marie
le pen también se quedó ahí me leyson
cuidado estamos hablando de extremos de
un lado y de otro que esto es muy
importante porque hay veces hay
políticos en europa y en españa que solo
les gusta hablar de un lado y queremos
que hablar de los extremos cualquiera
que sea su espectro ideológico
entonces yo creo que esperamos que en
esta presidencia macrón analice bien
estos datos y actúe en concordancia
porque el 19 de junio vuelve a ver
elecciones en francia y son legislativas
cuidado también allí porque suele haber
siempre un voto tal vez que sea distinto
por parte de los ciudadanos franceses y
que puedan pues lógicamente dar a las
opciones que no nos gustaría y
producirse un gobierno cohabitación que
cortaría un poco la acción de manuel
macro esperemos que no y que haya un
gobierno efectivamente
europeo y más necesario que nunca en
francia desde luego precisamente en la
siguiente pregunta es sobre es sobre
esta cuestión se ha demostrado este auge
de la extrema derecha algo que ya se
temía desde hace cinco años vemos cómo
siguen avanzando marie le pen ha doblado
el apoyo en estos cinco años han fallado
de alguna forma los partidos
tradicionales a la población que se
siente empujada a votar a esta extrema
derecha jose ramon vamos a ver lo que es
evidente es que hay tres nuevas
formaciones que han salido los últimos
años aparte de más de manuel macrón han
salido los populistas de extrema derecha
y de extrema izquierda de ambos extremos
y solamente uno de ellos ha coincida ha
coincidido con él o ha permitido el
coincidir en votos para en esta segunda
elección pero hay que para mí la lectura
es es importante no solamente en ese
sentido sino en lo que va a pasar a
futuro porque lo voy a decir de otra
forma en otras palabras es decir los
populismos que se están incrementando en
toda europa lo de francia es el último
de los resultados pero no más que un
hecho que avala el que la población está
muy hastiada del político que conocemos
habitualmente y del cual yo también
rechazó esos posicionamientos la gente
lo que quiere son políticos valientes
políticos que digan lo que piensan y que
se lo digan con claridad y sin
eufemismos no políticos que quieran
quedar bien con todo el mundo y sobre
todo con los titulares cada día está
aprendiendo a la prensa precisamente es
el caldo de cultivo es lo que fomenta la
distancia entre el votante de cualquier
país y el político que tiene delante por
lo tanto cuanto más alejado cuanto más
distancia vea el ciudadano del político
porque no habla su idioma porque no
empatiza porque le está haciendo
propuestas de cosas que ni siente ni le
importan pero a lo que tiene que
proponer y por tanto un 30 por ciento un
28% de abstención también es un modo
significativo de ver que algo está
pasando algo está fallando por lo tanto
necesitamos políticos valientes
políticos coherentes sensatos
congruentes con su pensamiento pero
sobre todo valientes y sin cobardías a
decir la verdad todo lo contrario sería
fomentar y alimentar esos populismos que
no son más que respuestas sencillas a
problemas como obligados en un momento
de mucha dificultad para todos los
países de europa y para europa en su
conjunto justamente hacía referencia a
esta cuestión antes antonio también
estabas hablando de también del auge de
essalud menciones todo muy estuvo casi a
punto
de
estar muy cerca de marine lepén de hecho
si se suman a ambos tanto marie le pen
como me leen son vemos que la mitad de
los electores franceses optaron por bien
la extrema derecha o bien por la extrema
izquierda que nos dicen estas cifras es
un voto protesta es que necesitamos
recetas o incluso respuestas fáciles
indudablemente si tengo que hacer alguna
crítica de manuel macro no es que
sinceramente estos últimos cinco años
tampoco es que haya producido unas
reformas espectaculares en francia que
eran necesarias la clase trabajadora se
ha visto alienada de este asunto y está
optando en estos momentos por opciones
que es fácil caer en ello es normal es
muy atractivo son formaciones que
normalmente no tienen ninguna aspiración
a llegar al gobierno se sienten muy
cómodos en la oposición es muy fácil
estar criticando y dando fórmulas
mágicas a estas formaciones es cuando
luego llegan a un gobierno ha habido
casos en la política europea y estuvo si
paras no en grecia y duró lo que duró en
fin también hemos tenido algún
experimento en austria
y al final no cuajan no cuajan porque se
descubre la terrible realidad que ni
existen fórmulas mágicas para solucionar
los problemas de europa o de un país ni
fórmulas de un minuto que esto se
arregla mañana por la mañana como van
ofreciendo por ahí estos partidos de la
extrema derecha izquierda sino una
política razonable ahora también
siguiendo un poco en consonancia con lo
que se ha dicho efectivamente también
hacen un análisis donde hemos fallado
nosotros dónde está ese alejamiento
entre el político tradicional razonable
equivocado o no moderado de izquierdas o
derechas donde hemos perdido ahí la base
y cómo recuperarla
siendo siempre partidos con vocación de
gobierno que es muy distinto de lo que
está lo que estamos viendo en los
últimos tiempos y siempre tenemos que
dar una alternativa democrática tenemos
que encontrar esa fórmula para poder
debatir y al final conseguir que
democráticamente los que votan estas
opciones que yo no les culpabiliza de
nada que yo no digo sino simplemente que
lógicamente la situación les ha empujado
a ese voto como los podemos
es un modelo en el cual partido europeo
y otros estamos pues lógicamente
trabajando para poder volver a recuperar
esa confianza aún así a meryl depende de
estas elecciones el ha visto por primera
vez mucho más presidenciable por así
decirlo hombre ya ha rebajado mucho el
tono de su discurso
antieuropeo algunos dirán euroescépticos
claramente antieuropeo de sus posiciones
iniciales de su padre pues ha habido una
evolución y tal vez por eso pues ha
habido más gente que se ha sentido
atraída en la seguridad de que
supuestamente una persona que fue
financiada y está juzgado y sentenciado
en francia por ser financiada por putin
que no es precisamente un valedor de los
principios de estabilidad y democracia
en europa pues lógicamente qué es lo que
hubiese ocurrido si hubiese llegado al
gobierno pero en su táctica electoral
había rebajado mucho ese tono de
antieuropeo vio detectó también que pasa
en otros países poder pasar en españa
puede pasar en italia donde el señor
salvini también ya casi le hace falta a
rodearse una bandera europea el problema
es cuando luego llegan al gobierno
ya veremos ahí qué es lo que pasa
antes hacías mención sobre los próximos
cinco años qué va a pasar después de
macrón tiene que recuperar la confianza
recoger una sociedad muy fracturada será
capaz sin ningún tipo de dudas y en ese
sentido también hay recogiendo un poco
el hilo de seguimiento de lo que decía
perfectamente esto no hay que tener en
cuenta le pen ha modificado modulado su
discurso no por por necesidad no por
convicción es decir lo que necesitaba es
unos votos que sumar para poder llegar a
ser la presidenta pero es esa mutación
continua y constante no es más que una
mutación por necesidad no una mutación
de convicción no lo estamos viendo
además cómo se ha ido incluso al lado
más obrero al al más intervencionista al
lado más pseudo europeísta sabiendo que
su socio preferente en este caso del
cual ha establecido una equidistancia
muy higiénica es putin por lo tanto no
debemos obviar cuál es la verdadera
realidad de los hechos y cuál es la
máscara que se algunos se ponen para
llegar a intentar conquistar al
electorado y en referencia a lo que
comentaba pues macro no obviamente tiene
un reto tiene dos dos retos desde mi
punto de vista primero va a tener que
actuar modelando las necesidades de esta
nueva etapa que es totalmente diferente
a su anterior etapa de gobierno y en
segundo lugar tiene un reto sumamente
importante que yo creo que mucha gente
todavía no lo pone no lo pone sobre la
mesa pero que debemos al que debemos
anticiparnos que es que serán las
últimas elecciones a las que se pueda
presentar macro tienen no solamente el
reto de consolidar su gobierno de dar
las respuestas en un momento difíciles a
su sociedad con coherencia sabiendo que
se van a cometer errores pero no nunca
van a ser populistas pero tiene un
objetivo que también le supera a él que
es dejar a su delfín dejar a su sucesor
es que él no puede permitirse acabar su
etapa presidencialista sin que su
partido tenga una opción de recambio a
futuro sobre todo ante estas amenazas
que tenemos de populistas pues tanto el
reto de macrón es doble el consolidado
un gobierno en el cual ya sabemos que va
a haber modificaciones con respecto a la
anterior etapa por las necesidades del
momento y sobre todo repito no dejemos
nuevo al aire tiene que encontrar su
sustituto para seguir
mandando al futuro social de los
franceses cuál es su futuro legado en
continuidad de partido la política
exterior durante esta campaña se ha
podido ver muy claramente en la cuestión
por ejemplo de la guerra de ucrania
hemos visto como el manual macrón ha
ejercido un importante liderazgo
reuniéndose ella hablando con
vladimir putin me parece que tiene
reservas a antonio ha sido acertado
entonces su papel pero alguna reserva y
esta vez si tengo que ser crítico creo
que el presidente de la república
francesa
estos próximos cinco años tiene que
aumentar un poquito que se ha perdido se
ha perdido la influencia que tenía esa
figura ya fue ya empezó con françois
hollande estamos hablando que el
presidente anterior nicolas sarkozy para
la invasión rusia en georgia se plantó
el georgia de la mano también de
americanos pero francia y eeuu y los
socios europeos consiguieron frenar la
ocupación rusa parte de georgia
de esos tiempos ya no tenemos un presión
de la república francesa en este sentido
en materia exterior quiero recordar dos
episodios solamente recientemente en la
política francesa uno el intento de
mediación de macrón en el líbano donde
fue echado a patadas por hezbollah las
cosas como son y segundo esa mesa de no
sé cuántos metros que separaba a macro
ni a putin por cierto echan valencia es
que propiamente en un programa de radio
del orgulloso
manufacturador de esta mesa que la de
valencia en fin ahora
yo creo que él tiene que plantearse como
decías es ramón con esa con ese
conocimiento de que no va a volver a
repetir
apostar un poquito más en esa cuestión
de las políticas exteriores europeas
muchísimas gracias antonio jose ramon
lamentablemente nos hemos quedado sin
tiempo estaremos pendientes estos
próximos cinco años a ustedes les
esperamos en el próximo programa de
europa hoy gracias por ver france24 en
español
[Música]